so for I uh drill one is pretty much the
same but you can add to you can add to
drill one and drill one is just your
standing
meditations uh your key accumulations
those kind of exercises so remember uh
align your middle toe midfoot weight
start to release muscle uh create some
sort of lifting or being held up energy
the spine all the way the chakra okay
and then uh let everything drop release
release release eventually you'll feel
everything drop what I feel you might be
different is I feel like when it
drops there's like a little pinch in my
spine because of the curve the curve of
the spine and so what you do after you
get this big radical expansion through
here as everything drops and opens I
just kind of Tuck that tailbone in
enough to release
that pinch point which is a y young
Clash point just release it okay and
then to this uh we can
add this kind of mudra of cheese sinking
here in the lower tonen uh my hands are
going to be uh open um at the palm area
and I kind of float them Lally between
lifting so I'll feel the the uh Yin pull
and the kind of pushing now I'll feel
the Yami push okay and I kind of hang
out
there and this feeling that I have on
what my tissue is doing in what more
importantly what my mind is doing that
is what I bring into the other drills
aside from the midfoot
okay uh so in this first next iy drill
he's just going to put his arms here
okay and I will
be in my base and he's going to lift his
arms up okay and I'm going to lay my
same Palms I had here I lay that Palm on
there
and as he lifts I'll pull it forward
without hooking
it do the other
side add the weight
shift
okay we'll try that so this one he
starts at the top now okay he's in that
horse stance and I still have my palm
don't hook anything I'm just flat okay
he drives down and I pull
[Music]
okay let's try so he has his arms and
this way uh we'll start he's he's going
to go up but this time we on the back of
my hand okay and this gets rid of the
curlers the curlers that can't stop
curling their fingers okay so it's on
the back of my
[Music]
hand
and then we can do the next Dr too he's
at the top and he's on the back of my
head so my hands flat don't come up and
curl
boom okay uh drill six is starts like uh
drill two but I do that small counter
okay so in drill two of the CQ line he's
pushing and I ground that okay okay now
what I'm going to do is ground the I key
so he's pushing again and I'm grounding
the I
key so he if you come closer camera I'm
flat on his hands okay it's not that
he's like Ramsey Dey where he's trying
to push out and that's what generates
the friction it's in those earlier
drills I used a counter energy to help
gain the sensitivity but here I don't
have a counter enery energy uh in the
sense that he he pushes out and then I'm
pushing in that's not what's happening
okay so uh it's just I'm here if he
brought his hands in I would of course
bring my hands in more to to keep that
friction there
okay but he's still trying to do de do
push okay it's just
here by the side you can go right to the
counter and you can't I'm using the
adhesion now to do the same positional
Integrity
okay all right all right I come around
and then I'm here and she's trying to
push switch these
sides you're pushing
okay we'll switch
sides do the
counter B
and then try to get rid of those hooks
there you
go and need to
relax and Camera get
closer and what's
happening a slipping you see
okay
again stick there it is now keep that
feeling release the tension out of your
body just keep the feeling all along
your body don't just focus at the
contact Point feel it all in your body
so it feels like every other drill You'
been
doing
better it's about inside your
body feel there it is right there and
just keep that and it's the standing
meditation what's inside your body don't
just get stuck on the contact
Point okay seven we do uh fi
Uno but from the adhesion so I go Y Line
to Y line through his Center okay say
again okay let's
try
so in the C
drills it's there's a built-in Center
catching you got to catch the center
okay so uh he Co drills it starts out
you don't even know you're doing it okay
you so you most people just move back
here and then move back forward like on
Dr uh number two D number three okay so
they're doing fi Uno but right here
there's a
catch right where you catch it boom and
then back but most people wait
and it's caught but only butter
prescription okay as we move into the
next drill where you don't come back to
Y phase but only the Y phase here that
catch is very
important so he catch
boom you then you get the balce more so
catch boom oh then as you go on the
catching becomes way more important um
so as we going forward there's a catch
that I'm doing internally that's what is
allowing that to happen and then we go
to drill 7 there's a catch when I come
in there's a catch what's the catch the
catch is that his tanden and my tanden
are in that iy state there's a kind of a
sense here like if he was throwing uh go
grab us one of the heavy balls as he
catches as he throws it I don't go
that's not what I do okay as as he
throws itom I catch it I go with it
catch it okay catch it this is the same
thing I'm doing the center catch it boom
okay and that becomes even more
important as you're doing the uh iy ver
variance because you don't have the
ledges or the of the grip nor the
mechanics of the grip so you have to
catch it
catch catch
okay boom catch boom all right pay
attention Okay drill eight to the Y Line
so this one I do catch it on the back
foot but then I don't go past the yin
then Yin is ankle straight okay uh so
catch ankle straight catch ankle
straight catch ankle
straight attach ankle straight it's very
important uh what why I like these iy
drills is there's the desire to throw
and as you desire to throw you're going
to start to slip because you're going to
out Yong the Y aspect of him and you'll
slip
okay um or you start to grab or you look
for Ledges of some kind okay so you have
to your hands basically boom just kind
of fly out exactly like Pom My Hands
just fly out there so I come out keep
the feeling boom feeling catch boom okay
let's try through mind is going forward
uh and again a lot of the skills in
order to climb the sequence I I'm not
telling you what you're doing again that
gets in the way for most people the ego
tripartite mind will aim for that
instead of the feeling okay um so I kind
of leave it leave the drills to work
their magic on their own and when the
student feels something I and and I can
sense that they feel it then I just keep
doing that keep feeling that keep
feeling that okay that's the best way of
learning this all right so uh when we
have the cut drils it looks like he has
his
grip and some people will be using the
grip so you use their
friction and the fact that your arm gets
wider here so you use that anatomical
ledge of the widening forearm to
generate that
projection point but if you were doing
it right you're inside you're inside the
grip and you have that same adhesion you
were you you were doing it right uh if
you're doing it right you were doing it
without Reliance on that physicality and
then pushing through you would feel his
grip and your inside his grip okay so
we're not really doing anything
different we're just taking away the
anatomical possibility of the grip of
using the grip okay as as we go on in
this drill it's a little bit more
complicated because we have to walk
towards each other and somewhere in
there I got a counter uh I like what the
complexity does because sometimes I
don't get the perfect uh point I might
get one hand half in grip one hand not
in grip you can still do the projection
okay so just let the magic happens but
as far as everything else it's exactly
the
same
[Music]
okay let's try and uh Dr 10 is the
same so from out of the horse stance
into the
[Music]
projection
okay let's try